fresh out of college I went to work for
a consulting firm during orientation the
leaders dished out advice amongst them
was one pithy counsel I will never
forget
he told us be easy to manage considering
how naive I really was at the time I
took his advice to heart I told myself
yes I will be the ultimate team player I
will do everything I'm told I will be
easy to manage
it wasn't until I arrived in graduate
school and witnessed firsthand the
criminal actions of scientists and
engineers in the water crisis in Flint
Michigan that I realized how dangerous
and yet surprisingly common this line of
thinking really is make no mistake the
Flint water crisis is one of the most
egregious environmental injustice of our
time for over 18 months a hundred
thousand residents including thousands
of young children were exposed to
contaminated drinking water with high
levels of lead lead is a potent
neurotoxin which causes cognitive and
developmental disabilities and is
especially harmful to growing fetuses
and young children we've known about its
dangers since the Roman Empire amongst a
whole host of health issues twelve
people died by contracting Legionnaires
disease Flint's water infrastructure the
complex network of underground pipes has
been severely damaged and while the
water quality slowly improving and the
pipes are being replaced now more than
two years later the water is still not
safe to drink so people are still in
shock they asks themselves how could
this have happened
the short answer is the crisis began
when an emergency manager appointed by
Michigan's governor decided to switch
their waters
source to a local river to save money
but it continued for so long because
scientists and engineers at government
agencies in the state of Michigan and in
the federal government did not follow
federal regulations for treating the
water right what was more they actively
cheated on the law and orchestrated
cover-ups they ridiculed residents
asking for help while publicly insisting
that the brown smelly water coming out
of the tap was safe to drink the system
at the local state and federal levels
completely failed to protect our most
vulnerable and an entire population was
left to fend for itself now amidst this
injustice Flint residents were rallying
together and amongst them were some
amazing women a flint mothers concerned
about their kids who came together
forming many grassroots coalition's and
these groups started protesting and
demanding change the group also reached
out to outside scientists for help and a
fear responded amongst them was a guy
named Miguel del Toro a water expert at
the US EPA the Environmental Protection
Agency who actually wrote the scientific
memo and sent it to the state of
Michigan and the federal government to
bring their attention to this problem
he was characterized a rogue employee
and silenced in collaboration with Flint
residents our research team here at tech
of students and scientists led by
Professor Marc Edwards conducted
citywide testing to prove that Flint's
water was indeed contaminated even toxic
in some homes we substantiated what
Flint had been screaming for months and
put it on the internet for the world to
see now when I was getting involved when
I said yes to this I had no idea what I
was getting into but every second of
this journey has been totally worth it
this was science and service to the
public this is what I came to graduate
school for and this is how I would
rather spend my life
and so this coalition this unlikely
coalition of citizens pastors
journalists and scientists came together
to uncover the truth using science
advocacy and activism a local
pediatrician figured out that the
instances of childhood lead poisoning
had indeed doubled in Flint during the
crisis and the state of Michigan was
forced to acknowledge the problem and
take steps to correct it this group and
many others God Flint's capes protected
a few months later President Obama came
in and declared a federal emergency and
now Flint is getting more than six
hundred million dollars in health care
nutrition education and overhauling
their water infrastructure
however the arrogance and the callous
disregard for Public Health shown by
scientists and engineers at these
government agencies is beyond belief
these unhealthy cultures that are
festering in these groups where the
focus is on meeting regulations and
checking boxes as opposed to protecting
public health is just appalling just
consider this email that an EPA employee
wrote where she goes I'm not so sure
Flint as a community we want to go out
on a limb for the dehumanization of an
entire population could not be more
obvious now contrast that to the first
canon of engineering which in my opinion
should be the first law of humanity to
hold paramount the health safety and
welfare of the public
above all else this is the Hippocratic
oath we've rarely acknowledged let alone
embraced and so when scientists and
engineers very much like medical doctors
screw up people can get hurt even die if
our professionals and even students fail
to get that society pays a huge price
buried deep in history lies a character
I deeply admire an engineer named Peter
policinski
he lived in the time of the Soviet Union
and polchinski repeatedly got in trouble
for his radical honesty and willingness
to point out major flaws in the Soviets
mindless pursuit of rapid
industrialization everyone was expected
to follow orders coming from the top
anyone asking questions are offering
feedback was unwelcome the Soviets had
created the largest army of engineers
the world had ever seen and yet most of
them were mere cogs in a gigantic
machine heading for doom buttinsky on
the other hand implored engineers to
look at the economic political and
social consequences of their actions in
other words be more public focused his
fearless voice of reason was seen as a
threat to the political establishment
and Joseph Stalin had him executed in
1929
now Polanski's view on technocrats is
very different from one that is you know
still very popular still very common
that of a dispassionate researcher
working in his ivory tower lab or an
early engineer working in his cubicle
brilliant no doubt yet somehow cut off
from the world shows little emotion kind
of like Spock from Star Trek you know
this guy let's render this box salute I
I don't think I'll succeed
see I can't be Spock
thank goodness I can't be spark now I
was reminded of this distinction because
a recent article came out in a very
reputed scientific journal which kind of
characterized our Flint work as driven
by youthful idealism and Hollywood's
dramatic sensibilities it asks
scientists to protect their research
funding and institutions at all costs no
matter how just the cause and if you
think you have to get involved into
something even if it's an emergency
try finding
an activist group or an NGO and obtained
the full support of the academic
community whatever that means before you
get involved not one mention of our
moral and professional obligation of
preventing harm to the public or the
fact that we have all these expertise
resources and for some even tenure to
you know accomplish this task I'm not
saying every scientist should be an
activist there are real and sometimes
very painful consequences of speaking up
but to denounce this idea this
possibility so completely so that you
can protect research funding simply
screams of self-serving cowardice and
this is not how the ideals that we would
want to pass to our students and so you
know you may think okay all this sounds
great but you'll never completely change
organizational cultures or you know
imbibe mindsets in students and
professionals to look at their work as a
public good you know science in service
to the public
maybe so but could a big reason for that
be that we are not training our students
right because if you look closely our
education system today is focused more
on creating what X Yale professor Bill
Theresa wits calls excellent sheep young
people who are smart and ambitious and
yet somehow risk-averse timid
directionless and sometimes full of
themselves now kids you know we fell in
love with science when we were kids and
yet we somehow spend most of our time
during high school and college just
jumping through hoops and doing things
so that we can polish a resume instead
of sitting down and reflecting on what
we want to do and who we want to be and
so the markers of empathy in our college
graduates have been dropping
dramatically in the past two decades
while those of narcissism are on the
rise there is also a growing culture of
disengagement betwee
Engineering students and the public you
know we are trained to you know build
bridges and solve complex problems but
not how to think or live or be a citizen
of this world my undergraduate ears were
explicit job preparation and I cannot
tell you how suffocating and painful it
was at times and so some people think
the solution to great engineers to great
scientists is more technical training
maybe so but where are the discussions
on ethical decision making or building
character or discerning right from wrong
consider this project that I deeply love
and admire it's called heroic
imagination project a brainchild of dr.
Phil Zimbardo famous for the Stanford
Prison Experiment this program seeks to
Train school-going children around the
world to look at themselves as heroes in
Waiting or heroes and training so these
young minds work overtime to develop
skills and virtues so that when the
opportunity comes no matter what the
opportunity be to stand up and do the
right thing in other words anyone can be
a hero think about that idea for a
second why don't we teach science and
engineering like that where heroism and
public service are seen as key values
because indeed it's often heroism that
is not only the antidote to public
indifference but also the systemic evil
like we saw in Flint and so dream with
me what a 21st century scientist /
engineer could look like individuals who
are driven to master the sciences so
that they can serve society and are also
aware of the tremendous power their
knowledge and decisions have folks who
are developing their moral courage at
all times and who realize that conflict
and controversy are not necessarily bad
things if our ultimate loyalty is to the
public
and the planet and so these are the
people who will stand up like we did in
Flint not to be saviors or heroes in the
media but altruistic and fundamentally
good actors that you and I can trust
imagine fostering such a public focused
mindset in classes and on service trips
and during activities during college or
even high school so that these young
minds will hold on to those ideals when
they actually enter the real world
whether that be consulting academia
policymaking or even becoming the
president of a country some of mankind's
greatest challenges lie ahead of us
contaminated drinking water is just one
example we could definitely use more may
we desperately need more compassionate
upstanders and public focused scientists
and engineers who will strive to do the
right thing and not be easy to manage
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]